faux
mars et avril 2020 le québec est en
crise c'est la panique les ch à celle
des les hôpitaux les écoles et garderies
fermées le chômage et l'économie en
ruine domine l'espace public ce dont
personne ne parle
c'est de protection de l'enfance comme
partout dans le réseau
les portes ne s'ouvrent pas facilement
la dpj de la mauricie nous permet enfin
de suivre ces travailleuses d'essentiel
oublier à la fin avril
ici à enquête nous n'en sommes pas à
notre premier topo sur ce milieu très
affecté par l'épuisement et la surcharge
de travail
mais ce printemps pour la première fois
les intervenants semblent avoir le temps
de souffler
j'ai vécu beaucoup de culpabilité au
début de culpabilité de quoi d'état jo
[ __ ] roche
c'est ça je vivais de la culpabilité
pour vrai on sait qu'il ya beaucoup
moins de signalements qui rentrent tous
les matins quand j'ouvre mon ordinateur
je toujours celle qui va vérifier les
dossiers en attente puis quand tu as
l'impression que tu atteins qui arrive
quelque chose mais qui en arrive pas on
peut pas se réjouir de ce vous aviez
combien de dossiers avant la pratique
environ une soixantaine de dossiers en
attente que pour plessisville
victoriaville ensemble et là maintenant
il y en a combien 0 c'est la détective
de la dpj
la première à se rendre chez une famille
après un signalement mais au printemps
plusieurs parents refusent d'ouvrir la
porte on avait souvent le commentaire
monsieur legault veut pas qu'on sorte
mais vous allez pas rentrer monsieur
legault dit qu'on doit rester à la
maison vous avez pas d'affaires à venir
contaminer mon milieu n'est pas question
que vous rentrez chez nous si moi je
peux pas sortir
j'étais en état d'urgence j'avais des
inquiétudes qui je voulais m'assurer
camille pouyalet bien pis surtout que
ils peuvent pas m'appeler ils peuvent
comme téléphone ayant 0 à 5 ans ils
peuvent ouvrir quelques rayons
pourraient de nouveau peur qui est maman
ou papa sont en état de consommation
son travail accompagner les petits de 0
à 5 ans à long terme
millie est la première à shawinigan à se
servir des réseaux sociaux pour
contacter les parents de ses clients
normalement c'est interdit
dès la mi mars elle leur envoient des
demandes d'amitié ils m'ont ajoutent ils
m'ont ajouté dans l'armagnac
oui oui ont collaboré quand que je dois
m'arrêter vidéo et quand j'ai zappé les
enfants avec leur téléphone les parents
circulent dans la maison
millie constate l'état des lieux en
direct mais juste d'avoir un frigo qui
fonctionne quel la nourriture dedans
l'assuré les enfants est de la place à
circuler que ça soit possible de ramper
sur ce taux plancher le facetime et
messenger ça fonctionne pour une semaine
ou deux après les parents répondent de
moins ou plus du tout moi ce que
j'allais en premier ne répondait plus et
répondait plus au téléphone
ne verrez plus non plus les messenger
fait qu avec un enfant en bas de 12 mois
je trouvais qu'il était vraiment
préoccupant puis quand je suis arrivé le
gvuc il m'a vraiment se tenir ce soir
parce qu'ils coûtent l'enfant était seul
dans sa chambre sa bassinette avec des
jouets la porte fermée
le papa gay mais les rideaux tous fermés
pour ceux que ça après une vue sur ses
enfants
ça prend un suivi ce suivi en personne à
la maison
encore faut-il pouvoir le faire
l'intervenante doit d'abord privilégier
le téléphone puis justifier la
pertinence de sa présence au domicile et
finalement se procurer masque visière et
jaquette de l'équipement quasi
introuvables au début est ce que vous
avez eu de la difficulté à vent de
l'équipement je t'aime pour ce champ
d'honneur d'intervention ça serait plus
mon syndicaux qui devrait la consigne
c'était de se rendre à l'hôpital qui est
à 24 kilomètres de notre point de
service pour aller chercher un ensemble
de protections vous deviez faire 25 km
pour aller chercher un équipement
revenir à plessisville pour faire une
intervention à plessisville par exemple
ça pouvait demander le une heure et
demie de temps de plus que
l'intervention au monde pour aller
chercher l'équipement d'un coup on ne
l'avait pas porté on devait retourner
l'hôpital reporter le matériel parce que
on peut pas le garder avec nous donc
refaire une heure de voiture vous avez
au moins dans les premiers jours on
avait des directives le qui descendait
du ministère à tous les jours un peu la
cohue
il est éducateur spécialisé et il
travaille à trois-rivières ici dans
l'unité de quarantaine du centre
jeunesse de la mauricie depuis la fin
mars
tous les jeunes de la région qui arrive
en centre d'accueil passe
obligatoirement quinze jours en
isolement préventif ici le fameux masque
est une barrière et pas uniquement
contre le virus
on a des jeunes qui sont pas toujours
habile pour décoder non verbale
c'est vrai quand le pneumatique c'est
encore plus vrai quand un masque fait il
faut souvent leur disait loeb juste et
les morceaux s'il faut vraiment y nommer
ce qu'on vit à voix haute parfois parce
que les jeunes arrivent pas à aller ou
envisagent le masque et aux nageoires
relationnel très important la tentation
est grande de l'enlever excessivement
grave
l'unité de quarantaine a été établi
rapidement dans un secteur vide de ce
bâtiment
on y suit les règles strictes isolement
d autres jeunes
prise de température deux fois par jour
ici les jeunes ne touche à rien le pot
cervelle en verre d'eau ou en verre de
l'air vraiment tout faire à leur place
parce qu'on veut éviter qu'ils évitent
même de permettre sa poche de l'est fait
que c'est l'adulte contrôler toutes les
villes objets finalement vous êtes là
servent à le recevoir et leurs
animateurs et leur meneur de jeu à temps
plein depuis la mi mars dans des
conditions draconiennes
du moins au début dans les premiers
jours et semaines on en est on
aujourd'hui comme une directive de ne
pas sortir l'extérieur car les jeunes
arrivés il ya le pôle l'opportunité de
jeu celle prendre l'air pendant deux
semaines pendant du genou pas de sorties
à l'extérieur
comment vous avez survécu ces premières
sa mère s'était enflammé de le tenir
occupés alors parce que si tu es enfermé
pendant 14 jours dans un endroit pour
sortir puis tu peux pas cette approche
de personnes mais [ __ ] santé mentale
c'est pour ces pôles idéal
c'est sûr que sur le concept vu qu'est
ce qu'on va faire pour animer ces jeunes
là
du matin au soir parce que c'est quand
même très adolescent qu'on a trouvé des
façons de dépenser l'énergie
c'est le défi du printemps pour
l'éducatrice mélanie brochu et ses
collègues animé constamment des jeunes
en difficulté des jeunes privés de leurs
parents de leurs médecins que leur
psychologue et de leurs enseignants
on a cette fois des jeux éducatifs avec
eux on leur parle des films en anglais
pour travailler leur anglais on fait des
quizz de jéhovah ça fait presque semaine
je crois qu on est en manque d'idées
beaucoup à court d'idées mais surtout à
court de ressources de façon presque
inimaginable
en 2020 on n'a pas internet nous non
plus qui était accessible pour les
jeunes fait que les jeunes à la maison
peuvent aller fouiller
il ya le sur le portail de l'école faire
des choses de façon autonome et nous on
n'a pas ces équipements à leur fournir
pas d'internet très peu d'ordinateurs et
au début pas même de tablettes pour voir
ses parents virtuellement car début mai
aucune visite de parents ou d'amis n'est
encore autorisés à l'intérieur ou à
l'extérieur des centres d'accueil
c'est inhumain aussi c'est comme les
fonds communs dans les résidences pour
personnes âgées
on peut pas les couper dans leurs
familles
pendant des mois et des mois le terme
inhumain et gelé entendu souvent la part
des parents qui trouvent exténué mais
qui devait être un contact avec leurs
enfants pour des périodes plus prolongée
19 mars 2020 une date passée presque
inaperçue pour la première fois de
l'histoire de la dpj
un arrêté ministériel suspens tout
contact physique entre les enfants
placés en familles d'accueil et leurs
parents il ya des parents qui voyaient
leurs enfants toutes les semaines depuis
la fois par semaine des fois une fois
par mois
donc quand ça tombe sur le contact une
fois par mois et c'est pesant pour eux
ça génère énormément d'émotion
énormément de colère la frustration née
compréhension pour qu est ce qu on vous
disait au téléphone bon pleurer et
beaucoup beaucoup de pleurs et beaucoup
de ça m'a dit cela en fallait se
souvenir d'eux
m
sa passagère
si j'avais pas mal connaître cette maman
est une cliente de l'intervenante
nathalie pépin qui a accepté de nous la
faire rencontrer ses deux enfants sont
placés en famille d'accueil à socke et
quand j'ai pris difficile car les
visiteuses intérêts touche crois pas
soit déjà logé voyage beaucoup je vais
pouvoir les prendre dans les boîtes
j'adhère je n'ai pas pris encore par les
pros pendant près de deux mois de la mi
mars au début mais jennifer n'a pu voir
ses enfants que par caméras interposées
coup j'arrive du camés roche jeudi un
point que je sais pas si c'est positif
c'était négatif ou la journée que
j'avais ma vidéo caméras étaient
contents de notre ans j'avais la main
armée commis d'office comme jennifer a
souffert de cette séparation forcée mais
ces enfants probablement moins selon
leur intervenante en fait tous les
professionnels à qui nous avons parlé
ont remarqué la même chose sans visite
de leurs parents les enfants placés sont
très souvent apaisé souvent les contacts
les pertes elles sont contents d'avoir
le contact que leur parent mais il ya
des choses qui se passent dans les
contacts pileux elle le apprécié de
pouvoir le parent se sont mêlés dans
tout cela c'est de tout petit milieu
exemple il y en a qui y étaient pas
propre à sa propreté été difficile
puisque va se tasser convaincre les
parents ben y rester et le ben écoute ya
plus de dérégulation site enfants le
lait ça fera prêter est réglé moi je
m'attendais que ça serait très
problématique
j'étais quand même étonné de voir que ça
coulait à pic les enfants étaient bien
c'est correct
on comprend notre choix aussi le maximum
que l'épisode 12 de 10 millions de
déclarations à la dpj qui nous font un
balancé pour une ouverture plus rapide
nous sommes le 27 avril d'ici deux
semaines écoles et garderies vont
rouvrir en région le plus grand souhait
des intervenantes et exaucer les enfants
vulnérables sortiront de chez eux
on peut drôle et à l'épicerie n'ont pas
le droit d'être dans les magasins il n'y
a pas d'école donc on l'y voit plus ses
enfants là donc on peu de gens s'en
inquiète parce qu'on ne peut pas
observer le ce qui se passe dans ces
milieux est ce que les parents vont
envoyer ses enfants dans les garderies
n'enverront pas toutes leurs enfants guy
c'est la peur du chaos vie douce et la
peur de se faire dénoncer est un peu des
deux
11 mai c'est le grand retour des
garderies et des écoles primaires en
région après deux mois
les intervenantes de la dpj pourront
enfin rencontrer les enfants cela seul
donc actuellement on va chercher
l'enfant l'école sans avertissement sans
informer aucun des parents pour éviter
l'autre la version du jeu ne soit
contaminée on rencontre cet enfant
l'autre ce qui sera possible seulement
si les enfants retournent à l'école mais
ce n'est pas tout à fait ce qui s'est
produit ce qu'on comprend c'est que
c'est pas nécessairement non familles
vulnérables qui sont retournés à l'école
on a beaucoup de nos familles qui ont
gardé les enfants à la maison
combien d'enfants dont vous êtes
responsables sont retournés à la
garderie 2 2 sur 21
êtes vous déçu pour certains oui
certains parents peut-être qu'ils ont
peur qu'il y avait plus de répercussions
qu'un clore enfin était à la garderie
parce que bon il ya des choses qui fait
des pinces à marcory est qu'il faille
signalé par réel les éducatrices frein
pas alors que des parents refusent de
laisser leurs enfants sortir d'autres
n'ont plus le droit de les voir du tout
parce qu'ils sont placés en famille
d'accueil
jennyfer aura finalement été privé de
ses enfants pendant 50 jours
depuis le mois de mai elle a droit de
les revoir
mais pas de les toucher
même josé les premiers contacts ça se
fait avec les jaquette d'hôpital avec
les masques
le maillage de la distance quand ça fait
contrôler quatre montées au pot vue puis
que tu peux prendre intégraux sais pas
ce qui est mieux pour garder des liens
sociaux
c'est au moment du départ qu'ils
puissent difficile mais désiré bien coté
puig aux autres pourquoi pendant que des
biscuits sauter la seule fille pour la
bo du pipeau dire un enfant non te
pendre et 1,40 à mort elle a 9 ans c'est
la fille de jennifer
nous l'avons rencontrée avec nathalie
son intervenante
je trouve que ça se fait pas d'après moi
j'trouve ça se fait peur parce que
j'aurai beaucoup beaucoup aimé il donne
un carnet pour la première fois depuis
quelques montées j'avais pas vu déjà que
j'avais pas souvent en vrai à la mi
septembre
la petite ne comprenait pas la politique
du gouvernement au sujet des contacts on
peut pas toucher nulle part sauf à
l'école
moi je trouve injuste touche à l'école
un spotify ailleurs 4 va voir ma main et
tout de suite ça marche parce qu on dise
tiens j'ai j'ai le droit de tuer des
boîtes de médicaments sans rien a écrit
j'ai pu voir des camemberts ou contacter
gilles ça marche on dit que c'est un
coin les contacts parents enfants
reprennent lentement à la fin du
printemps
mais pendant l'été les intervenantes
continue de ramasser les pots cassés par
les masques la distanciation et toutes
ses visites à nu les autres mais notre
l'honneur par exemple
non non non c'est par exemple se poser
soit passé des menaces ce que je
constate présentement c'est beaucoup de
colère exprimée dans l'agressivité
verbale souvent stéphanie lessard est
intervenante auprès des petits 0 5 ans
et de leurs parents à trois rivières
qu'est-ce qui vous disent les parents
veulent reprendre le temps avec leurs
enfants donc me remettre la faute sur
mon dos de en vélo mes contacts peuvent
pas se dérouler comme je voudrais sur la
même cadence selon les mêmes paramètres
j'ai des parents qui me raccroche au nez
je les parents qui vont crier après donc
ça fait partie de mon quotidien tulle
des parents qui veulent rattraper le
temps perdu face à des enfants souvent
stressés par le retour de leurs parents
dans leur vie on voit vraiment que les
enfants vont avoir tendance à moins bien
dormir les jours qui suivent à être
beaucoup plus fatigués à leurs photos ou
mourra faire des longues longues siestes
les lendemains surlendemain donc on va
voir vraiment des fois même des enfants
qui vont jeûner pendant quelques
quelques-uns à quelques journées oui
c'est un phénomène décrit par toutes les
intervenantes à qui nous avons parlé des
problèmes qui semblait réglé reviennent
comme ceux du petit client de milly
pajot celui qui avait cessé de faire
pipi au lit depuis qu'il ne voyait plus
ses parents pendant la pandémie
fuites problèmes de propreté tel allait
bien à ce niveau là et on reprend me
contacter sarsgaard
pis les crises et
st crise était vraiment moindre des
grosses crises de colère pendant la
pandémie est calme plus la pandémie
arrête la reprise de contact avec papa
maman tard comment allez vous mettre
dans votre rapport
oui oui à la mi juin
les intervenants que vous avez vu relaxe
malgré eux au début de ce reportage ne
l'était déjà plus depuis le début du
déconfinement bo
la vague est revenue un peu comme un
tsunami le jeu social dans le
transpondeur c'est on savait que ça
allait reprendre sauf que la cadence à
laquelle les choses reprennent
c'est difficile de garder le fil oui la
vente commence à évoluer mais on va
passer par un petit peu plus cet automne
cet automne pourquoi cet automne des
séparations avoir lieu nous en sommes
dans nos gènes ferme isma les conflits
de séparation âgées rue avec ce que ça
peut apporter comme son lot de problèmes
des difficultés avec les enfants le
tribunal de la jeunesse déjà engorgé
dans cette région n'acceptait plus que
les urgences ce printemps quatre mois
plus tard début octobre les délais
semblent avoir atteint des sommets ans
en 2021 pour des dossiers loki qui date
d'avant le confinement
donc il y aura deux des dossiers qui
vont être vu en 2021 et qui ont été
potentiellement signalait en 2019
possiblement qu'est ce que ça change ça
dans la vie d'une famille ça change que
yoyo pas de plans d'intervention avec le
parent trouve solent par confiance aussi
un système de justice
la pandémie a ralenti le système elle
semble aussi l'avoir un peu bousculée ça
ne s'était jamais fait à la dpj d'entrer
dans les maisons par caméras interposées
millie pajot s'attendait donc à ce que
les familles la bloque sur facebook ou
messenger
est-ce que ce qui s'est passé maintenant
maintenant on s'en doute rester puis
mais c'est correct c'est qu'elle puisse
convaincre a été testé la technologie
facilite le contact avec ses clients
mais c'est aussi un couteau à double
tranchant et en hockey et ils
comprennent que c'est dans les heures de
bureau
pierre nadeau ok c'est plus difficile de
comprendre qu'il ya des heures de bureau
mais c'est parfait comme si la pandémie
avait transformé la dpj en un immense
laboratoire
il l'a fait sortir de l'âge de pierre on
a finalement l'eau après des années de
demandes et d'espérance d'avoir droit à
des ordinateurs portables pour faire du
télétravail pour travailler ou tribunal
pendant les longues heures d'attentes
ça fait combien tu as vous demandiez
mots j'en rêve depuis show centre
jeunesse depuis dix ans il aura fallu
cette crise pour que les centres
jeunesse se modernise
des milliers de téléphones et
d'ordinateurs portables ont été
distribués aux intervenants en centre
d'hébergement
on est maintenant équipée pour favoriser
les contacts avec le monde extérieur
même en quarantaine on n'avait pas vu ça
il y en a donné une tablette jonas
angeles on a eu trop peur de silva sur
facebook que si par le recrutement pour
les réseaux blablate orlan car depuis on
supervise ça se fait très bien
l'unité de quarantaine où il travaille
est toujours en place
les signalements augmente les piles de
dossiers en attente
aussi elles feront face pourvu que les
écoles restent ouvertes pour vous le
pire ça serait selon un retour à la
maison
oui c'est sûr qu'un autre confinement se
serait et pays qui pourrait prendre
[Musique]
e
on
[Musique]